and thank you for joining us at 11 i'm
brian loftis friends of a teen hit and
killed crossing the street last week
celebrating his life with a balloon
release keith young jr died friday night
and today his grieving family reunited
with the woman who helped the team that
night madison kimbrough has the story
you will only see right here on 8 news
now
bringing a sense of closure to tragedy
as one witnessed a witness to hit and
run that happened right around in this
area that you're looking at right now
met with the victim's family today for
the first time since friday's incident
a 15-year-old boy is dead after being
hit by a car friday evening this was
near sierra vista high school at durango
and robindale keith young jr was
crossing the street with his younger
brother his brother survived but keith
did not desiree andre sin saw it all
unfold as she was sitting at the traffic
light near rhodes ranch i just got out
and i was just like oh my god oh my god
and got on the phone and called 9-1-1
and um he runs across the street and
he's like oh my he's my brother
this is what that's probably what's
changed me and he's just grabbing him
from behind and pulling him out of
traffic so he doesn't get hurt anymore
tuesday anderson met with keith's mother
nicole james for the first time you were
a mom at that moment and you kicked it
into gear
in the absence in my you stood in my
absence i could not go
another day another week another moment
without looking you in your eyes and
telling you how much
i appreciate
you regardless of the fact that my son
did not make it
your intent and your intention it was
just
it was life-changing the young family
wants justice for their son and will
continue to work with metro in finding
the driver that killed him
again this is the area in which the hit
and run took place metro is looking for
a red dodge charger with left front end
and windshield damage and a missing left
side view mirror the model of the car is
said to be between about five to seven
years old so look out for that reporting
live madison kimbrough 8 news now